hello reject nation it's greg alba here
it's John
so it's December 5th still have no
access to the channel so no idea when
this video is going up maybe well you're
lucky and they'll get freed up by
tonight maybe it's still the 5th or
watching this now or maybe it's the 20th
with that in mind guys we wanted to give
a shout out to today's video sponsor
thanks Jake over at stardom Jake just
shots Jake Jake allows you to do 30
seconds Stardust is this awesome app
that we have been using regularly I
really considered a part of the real
rejects community now 30-second
reactions for any film TV show or
trailer if depending on when you're
watching this video you'll see that
because we couldn't put stuff up on
YouTube Stardust and yeah follow us
there download and follow us first at
today's patron of the day shout out
we'll go out to JT anyway let's watch
this Pacific Rim uprising Tokyo comics
hot yo Drift 2017 real whoa some
Universal so they double monetize it oh
holiday paid Simon half
Wow estado I loved the first Pacific Rim
that classic tale of robots and monsters
that hold weights and that holds power
yeah yeah I grew up watching the old
giant Mari Steven that I can the
classics like Ultraman space Giants and
of course Godzilla I just ate it up
everybody felt that fleet in those
places is going through a city
it creates an instant excitement
with the technology we have we have a
chance to make it that much more
spectacular all the decor it there so
any content so ultimately it's a world
conflict and everyone has put aside
their differences and come together many
you enter this program you join a family
we stand that's what makes us strong
this is our time this is our chance to
make a difference I'll help me save the
world Pacific Rim our price it gives an
answer back to those monsters that we
burn up which we have Villegas
[Music]
I mean you're not actually doing
[Music]
[Music]
she's like a cooler version on servers
last night chick we set it for the
daytime fights they're getting real Star
Wars
[Music]
Swee
laser chainsaw hands which is also that
Yeager's name well dude I said it before
uh-huh I'm excited for this like when
I'm in the theater I think I'll be
excited for it I'm not like I have to
see this movie but when it comes out I'm
gonna feel like the anxiety of it came
out today I have to go watch it they
think about this featurette is they did
nothing to say what makes this different
from the first like minute and a half of
information was like yeah that's
specific written that's all you've
described that's kind of an astute
criticism is all I know is that
everybody had fun and it's gonna be
exciting but the Pacific it just looks
like a Pacific Rim movie they describe
the world like well you're not
elaborating on what makes uprising any
different yeah I don't know anything
amiss a sequel any different other than
what new stuff for our characters are
going to face there's some daytime
fights you know is that so that's the
only real new stuff I'm excited for is
the daytime fight sequences look pretty
neat but this feature it kind of makes
it look more like transformers in the
last one didn't I like that they are
going with the vibe of life here's a
bunch of behind-the-scenes footage
here's it looks like they built stuff
you know of course a good amount so
that's cool see but yeah it does sort of
look like monsters punching robots which
to be fair Pacific Rim is a lot of
people when they saw the last trailer I
saw it
way more when I saw the trailer like at
a movie theater oh yeah this this this
looks a lot like a Transformers movie I
will say though I think it'll be better
than any of the transfers that do not
like a single one of those movies I like
the vibe at the core of Pacific Rim a
lot better than I liked most any
transformers but even having the little
girl there I mean a lot of movies have
to go with the little kid who's awesome
but even having her here I'm like oh
it's transformers the last night now you
know so that does come to mind I want
this to be good but that's the one thing
I'm missing from all the advertising so
far as it is yeah what's gonna make this
one special and right right I'm for
rapid this video shout out today for JT
jate over at patreon JT is
like only he's in Hawaii but he's
Japanese just like we're this trailer
played JT I wanted to make sure we
specifically shout you out for this
video to honor your Japanese heritage I
mean to know that your family's history
specifically the JT lineage dealt with
kaiju and all kinds of monsters and
Asians and that's why you guys had to
come to America you guys are real heroes
I thought us having our channel you know
not having access to it was a real
struggle knowing that your family comes
from battling giant creatures well add
respect I could see why you're such a
serious guy when we talk on a Google
Hangouts yeah a little known fact Steven
s tonight actually stole that those
tattoo designs from JT got these two
giant buff tattoo arms and his yeah yeah
that too stole all of it subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell hey you could follow us on the
stardust app download and follow us
first people almost a two thousand
followers help us get there
become a patron eject today because it's
like a second youtube channel just more
free form it really is but post a lot of
videos over there uncensored draw the
raw rejects man